e aí
eu gostaria de fazer primeira vez uma
pergunta para você você se lembra qual
foi a sua maior prova de amor que você
já recebeu da sua vida a minha maior
prova de amor foi quando eu era
adolescente e eu resolvi perguntar para
minha mãe a seguinte pergunta mas se
você soubesse que eu parceria com
nanismo você a portaria a resposta dela
foi sim e antes vocês começa a julgar a
minha mãe por qualquer razão que seja
saiba que a resposta dela foi dada
obviamente baseado antes dela receber em
seus braços e foi uma prova de amor
muito grande porque a primeira vez
tratou como igual momento algum passou
pela cabeça dela amenizar a resposta só
porque eu era deficiente segundo que ela
foi em verdadeira ou nesta e sincera
porque ela tinha certeza de uma boa que
tinha entre nós dois então quando a
gente ama a gente essa confiança e falar
a verdade
a felicidade então uma jovem de 22 anos
estava sem que ela soubesse que ela
pudesse se preparar porque a médica não
falou para ela que eu nasceria com
nanismo estava em seus braços uma
criança que tinha uma displasia
diastrófica que é uma doença congênita
rara que é ocasionada por causa de dois
genes recessivos esses dias são
raríssimas da população ou seja duas
pessoas família esperei se encontrarem e
ter um filho com essa displasia é mais
difícil que ganhar na mega-sena sozinho
por baixo eu podia ter ganhado na
mega-sena mas tudo bem e ela e enfim ela
estava ali diante de seus braços com
aquela criança e aquelas jovens jean
duas opções na vida dela primeira opção
que ela tinha era rejeitado aquela
situação rejeitado tô falando aqui uma
coisa atrás para jogar no lixo
a doar para alguém dando é isso rejeitar
também seria aceitar o diagnóstico que
os médicos deram que eu não gostaria que
possivelmente não falaria e seria uma
ter uma criança ou adulto dependente
para o resto da vida ou fazer o que ela
fez aceitar que nada nessa vida é por
acaso
o teu sim e lutou com todas as suas
forças por aquela criança porque ela
acreditou texto primeiro momento que eu
era capaz e que eu sou igual a qualquer
outra pessoa graças a esse sim que sei
que ela soubesses ela mudou diversas
vida a primeira vida que ela transformou
foi a dela mesmo como ela mesmo me disse
uma vez que ela era uma jovem fútil que
só pensava em certa embalada com ela
roupa que ela ia vestir de uma hora para
outra essa mulher se transforma numa das
mais incríveis e admiradas mãe que eu já
vi em toda minha vida e uma excelente
educadora am
ah e também ela transformou a minha vida
porque eu pude verdadeiramente provar
que eu sou igual a todo mundo como que
foi feito isso primeiramente porque
graça essas duas pessoas e a mãe e minha
avó da família materna toda mesmo com
meu pai ter me largado porque não
aceitou aquela realidade minha família
paterna me deixar de lado tem as
educação dessas duas pessoas eu sou quem
eu sou hoje por quê porque elas nunca me
trataram e formas diferentes ela nunca
me trataram como coitadinho nunca
tiveram pena de mim sempre tratados de
forma igual tem outros irmãos que não
são deficientes e nem por isso eu fui
tratado as formas diferentes era cobrado
mesmo diante de três cirurgias que eu
fiz na minha infância minha adolescência
mesmo tenho que estudar no colégio eu
chego ter a melhor nota ser um bom aluno
porque eu era igual a todo mundo
inclusive o brasil na minha época tinha
apenas a gordinha do chinelo vou
e hoje em dia hoje em dia não pode mais
usar mandar para tia e eu também era
alvo do chinelo voadores é verdade só
que eu tinha uma vontade ela vai difícil
acertar é pequenininha ela complicado
para caramba envie essa foi uma
diferença mas aí graças a essa educação
graças a essa vida que eu levei eu
cresci com a certeza absoluta que eu sou
igual a todo mundo que eu posso fazer
tudo que eu quero igual a todo mundo eu
posso dirigir o meu carro como vocês
estão vendo e não é o hot wheels 1
é porque a senhora mais fácil eu posso
fazer uma faculdade eu poderia ter um
emprego construir uma família porque ela
me passaram essa verdade desse mundo
diferente que ainda incomoda tanta gente
sobre a postura que eu sou igual a todo
mundo graças a isso eu me formei eu
passei no vestibular para uff e ufrj
escolhi a uff niterói são joão de coreaú
e lá do flamengo da situação e sexta
computação nesse período eu prefiro
iniciação científica física presa júnior
enfim logo em seguida eu passei para o
mestrado e gerias soprando a cópia da
ufrj onde me informa aí mestre e aí eu
consegui graças a deus me identificar
quase sete anões não era o mestre e
e eu fui o orador da turma no carro da
graduação e enfim eu consegui um emprego
como estagiário numa das maiores
empresas televisivas o brasil logo em
seguida foi efetivado não estava
satisfeito com meu salário e aí resolvi
fazer o concurso hoje passei para
auditor de controle externo tribunal de
contas do município do rio de janeiro
onde ainda sua é concursado lá e graças
a deus sustenta a minha família e apesar
de toda essa história toda essa minha
vida tive uma outra vida outra história
paralela que é uma história artística
que tem pequenininho eu gosto de teatro
pequenininho não tem criança digitar
confusa né é caramba desculpa taís
criança eu sou eu sempre apaixonado pela
arte pula pro ar fazer teatro e só que
eu nunca quis eu sempre me apaixonar
pelo bom mas eu nunca quis fazer humor
que tu não já sabia que
o seu jordão estado já não leva torta na
cara hein filha eu queria falar tua não
também poderia fazer um motor de uma
forma protagonista e assim eu fui
crescendo essa ideia até que eu consegui
ganhar o prêmio multishow de humor onde
era o único deficiente competir com
todos os motoristas vários do brasil
inteiro diversas modalidades e a partir
daí minha carreira artística ficou mais
consolidada conhecido como gigante léo e
eu pude fazer nessas coisas novela
inclusive no papel na novela que época é
eu ah não ele não é falado muito sobre
isso ele era um dono de uma companhia e
filha foto esse adoro apenas um detalhe
físico do personagem e e assim foi até
que piso intestino que eu fosse
protagonista de um filme chamado altas
expectativas que foi o primeiro filme
brasileiro hoje a figura do ah não foi
protagonista
e na história ninguém falava da questão
do nanismo palavra história das disputas
do amor do meu personagem com o
personagem da camila márdila que era
lena e subir e cortar ou seja falava de
coisas como a qualquer outra pessoa e aí
essa questão da arte tornou-se muito
forte começou a tomar uma outra dimensão
na minha vida quando primeiramente eu
recebia uma mensagem e um grupo de
pessoas que têm a mesma tipo assim a
minha gente que ela tem informação uma
mãe que tá com a sua filha que era igual
a minha da uti e ela assistiu o filme e
ela falou chorando para mim da mensagem
que agradecendo por que ter me visto que
eu esperança para ela para que ela
pudesse ver a sua filha feliz e
dependente como eu estava sendo seja
naquele momento eu estava mais apenas
fazendo coisa para o meu prazer eu
estava representando uma voz e uma
se soubesse aquele se da minha mãe ainda
vai repercutir e por fim acho também
trouxe uma coisa louca porque no twitter
uma garota jovem ganhou o twitter
aleatóriamente uma peça que eu quase não
aconteceu e ela foi assistir essa peça
quase que ela vai assistir também e aí
desse encontro pouco provável pouco da
esperável eu encontro o grande amor da
minha vida que é a carol eu também
encontrei a minha sogra não sabia
e vai fazer né tem que prestar mais
atenção e eu comprei a carol essa pessoa
incrível que nunca me tratou as formas
diferentes ela a família dela sempre tu
é transforme igual ela nunca questionou
se a tássia tássia dá certo não ela
sempre meu amor sempre exigiu de mim foi
ciumenta como toda namorada é e sempre
me viu enfim como o seu namorado seu
amigo seu protetor ou seja eu sempre fui
para ela o seu rodrigo e o meu suspensão
fox e
ah não você só quer mais gostoso porque
é mais com seu paradiso aí ó
e e tenta amor desse amor brotou uma das
coisas mais incríveis que aconteceu na
nossa vida e é o nascimento da minha
filha luiza
e ela dá seu com 51 cm ou seja o meu
tamanho já arrancar ela não tem que
fazer as costas e mais uma vez a vida
mostrou para mim léo você é igual a
qualquer outra pessoa e foram grande
aprendizado que assim que ela nasceu
começou a vir e ver essas questões na
minha cabeça que tipo que tipo
super-herói é você para minha filha
porque os pais são super-heróis podem
tudo para jogos filhos para o alto eu ia
conseguir mais carregar com ele no colo
eu já não consigo mais carregar ela
direito que ela ela é grande e como eu
sou várias vários questionamentos até
que caiu a ficha e eu descobri e
apreende duas grande coisa a primeira é
que a vida tá me dando uma oportunidade
ímpar de hoje te dá para minha filha sem
precisar fazer nenhum discurso apenas
com a minha convivência de que todas nós
o super
e os nossos pais das somos frágeis e
isso não é motivo de vergonha e nem nos
pais maior nem menor que ninguém é uma
condição humana todas nós
verdadeiramente precisamos da ajuda de
um duas e o segundo ensinamento que o
bicho ficou muito foi que este público
pela primeira vez na minha vida eu tava
sempre preconceituoso comigo mesmo eu
coloquei as minhas dificuldades acima da
minha potencialidade com esse aqui eu
nunca prendi e que nunca foi ensinada e
aí eu fui dar conta disso quando a gente
deixou a gente tem gatos em casa a gente
achou os gatos gente claro que ele ficou
na parte de fora o isadora gato falar
vou deixar ela brincar para ver né que a
luiza e no momento que ela viu o gato
ela ficou morrendo de medo porque tava
dentro da sala a primeira reação dela
foi correr e meus braços por lá na minha
cabeça puxar meu cabelo acho que me
segurar para não sair enrolando
no passado e desse momento ela tá
falando para mim sempre pronunciar nada
pai você é igual a qualquer outro pai
saiu não importa só alto baixo loiro
gordo magro eu sou o pai dela e ela
confia que eu vou proteger elas qualquer
armazena na verdade na verdade ela tá
falando lá na minha alma lá tetra tipo
assim aí pai você não fala para todo
mundo que é igual a todo mundo você não
acredita nisso então haja haja como tá
porque para mim você sempre será meu pai
é o meu super herói e aí enfim eu
gostaria de fazer mais pergunta para
você tia será que você
é você que tá aqui realmente considera
que todos nós somos iguais será que a
sociedade considera que todos nós somos
iguais sobretudo as pessoas com
deficiência eu acho extremamente difícil
você encontrar alguém diretor de uma
grande empresa ocupando cargos
importantes direito será que não tem
deficiente habilitado para isso
certamente tem gente baixo pode ficar
até que o doutorado phd e por que que
eles não estão nesses lugares e segundo
gostaria de perguntar para você será que
você se considera verdadeiramente igual
a todo mundo ou da primeira vez na
história do espelho você está fora dos
padrões se sente inferior a outra pessoa
ou porque você não conseguiu emprego não
passou daquele cargos você queria
naquele meu irmão meu você se considera
inferior todo mundo eu acho que ele
considera não merece ser dor de alma e
sim isso também é preconceito por você
o porquê de oportunidade de chance para
as grandes surpresas que a vida pode
aprontar para cada um de nós tá aí um
exemplo começa a palestra ter essa
oportunidade para a vida sobretudo você
tem que acreditar em você porque esse
nem você acredita em você como vai
querer que o outro aquele gente porque
no fundo todos nós somos iguais apenas
temos dificuldade diferente é
e aí